hey 42 here at some point I'm sure many
of you have seen a list of the famously
non relevant interview questions as to
Google things like how much would you
charge to wash every window in Seattle
this is obviously a stupid question
because no one would pay you as it never
stopped raining in Seattle like ever
another question on the list is this
imagine a country where everyone only
wanted boys so if a couple have a girl
they have another child if they have a
boy than they stop what is the
proportion of boys to girls in the
country a difficult question and there's
a lot of debate over the correct answer
but most people come to the conclusion
that the answer is a 50/50 mix of boys
and girls but what we want to ask today
is do you really have a 50/50 chance of
having a boy or a girl are there any
genetic or environmental factors that
can affect it and is there really such a
black and white OP should I say blue and
pink difference between the genders so
in the words of some woman who likes to
stick meat on all her dresses why was I
born this way
humans have 23 pairs of chromosomes and
22 pairs are the same for both men and
women the 23rd pair though are the sex
chromosomes and women have 2x ones
whereas men have an X under Y where the
Y is much smaller than the X the X
chromosome has over 2,000 genes in it
whilst the Y has just 78 but before you
start thinking that women have cheated
by sneaking in a few thousand extra
genes to play with very soon after
fertilization one of the pair of X genes
in women almost completely deactivates
so we all end up with a similar number
in the end for the first few weeks is a
fetus male and females are basically the
same
then the genitals go their separate
directions but although we see the
equipment down there is being very
different it's more similar than you
would think the gonads IVA become testes
or ovaries the phallus becomes either a
penis or a clitoris which actually
extends a few inches it's just all
internal and the lobby ax and scrotum
are pretty similar bits of skin just
with a different let's say our gum it
takes until the 16th week of pregnancy
or later when we can peer in and see
what sex a baby actually is and realize
that we have to return all the pink
dresses we bought because it has a
dangly thing so when you see how
genitalia develop you could realize that
it's actually possible that they may not
develop fully in one direction since
they start as pretty similar stuff now
depending on the definition between 0.1
percent and 1.7 percent of people are
born biologically intersex since their
Anatomy doesn't fall strictly into one
category or the other it lands somewhere
in the middle it's also possible to have
both xx and XY chromosomes there's even
a very rare condition where the Y
chromosome gets tagged onto one of the
XX chromosomes many of these outcomes
are very rare because it's very likely
that these people won't be able to
reproduce so the characteristics
get passed on through the generations if
only the same could be true for people
who would like to refine their seats on
planes
I think we would all like the seat
recliner Jean to be deleted from the
population all right that's the
development part and all our dangly bits
out of the way but how do the cells of
you initially settle on their XX or XY
configuration do the sperm in the egg
arm-wrestle for it if you have a picture
of Vin Diesel above the bed does this
increase your chances of having a boy
right now
globally the sex ratio is a hundred and
seven boys for every 100 girls the
gender is decided by the sperm a man
produces two different sperm cells one
contains an X chromosome and the other
contains a Y chromosome so if the X
fertilizes the egg you get a girl and if
it's the Y it's a boy if it's desert
chromosome then you get a wizard
congratulations
as the X&Y contain different amounts of
genes like we mentioned before this
means that the x perm is actually 1.0
three times heavier than the Y sperm the
Y sperm is known to be more mobile but
the X has a longer lifespan so then it's
possible although not proven that
increased gravitational pressure during
and just after sex could have some
influence on the baby's gender so maybe
you should try sitting a bit differently
if you've already engraved Jessica onto
the crib there are many myths out there
about how you can influence the gender
outcome of a child from what point of
ovulation you have to have sex at 2 the
type of breakfast cereal you eat but
nothing reliable has ever been proven
the reason almost all species end up
with a 1 to 1 sex ratio is down to a
thing called fish's principle imagine
there are less male births than female
this would mean that a newborn male will
have more people to mate with than a
newborn female so any parents that have
a tendency to produce males will end up
with more grandchildren but then this
tendency will spread and soon the ratio
will change so the benefit of producing
males stops it's really only colony
species such as ants and bees where this
ratio doesn't apply any bees is
controlled by
fertilized egg being female and an
unfertilized one being male females who
are not destined for the queen hood are
also fed a restricted diet so that their
reproductive organs don't develop it's
the same reason why Prince Harry was fed
exclusively on pop-tarts Paulette fish's
principle is just a natural balancing
act but surprisingly there are
environmental factors that can alter the
human sex ratio for the population in
any given area
Ralph Catalano a berkeley professor
published two reports that set the
ambient temperature would change the
ratio and a 1 degree Celsius rise in
temperature could create what in a
thousand extra boys another
well-established phenomenon is that
after a war the birth rate of males
noticeably increases as if the great
galactic accountant is trying to balance
the books somehow but how is it possible
our genes can't exactly see all the
extra space around in the locker room
and think right it's mum making time
well dr. Curie gelati suspects it's
still all down to the fissure principle
if you are a man from a family with more
brothers than sisters that means you
probably produce more Y sperm than X
you're a man making machine
if your family is mostly sisters however
then you've likely got more expert
you're a female factory when a major war
comes and all the men get shipped off to
battle a family with more brothers has a
greater chance of having at least one
son returned alive from battle so there
was a bigger proportion of Y sperm bias
in the lads who finally returned when
the war is over that's all life is
really sperm and statistics of course no
matter what the sex of a newborn baby
over their lifetime they are going to
produce about six hundred large comes of
garbage and over ten million litres of
wastewater so maybe there are already
enough Dave's and Sarah's in the world
and I wouldn't mind finding a seat on
the train every now and then so perhaps
you should just adopt a cat instead
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 for this lakebed is littered
with hundreds of hundreds of skeletal
humour
remains then you could be an
extraordinarily intelligent person
possibly even genius level